[Music]
Aina of time is a Timeless genre
defining Masterpiece and no one on God's
green earth can ever convince me
otherwise yeah using the iron boots was
tedious the camera control sucks and the
graphics look like you took a piece of
origami and Drew a face on it but I
don't care about that I am not the
target audience for your criticisms or
your hot takes this game has cemented
itself so firmly into my brain that
whenever the word nostalgia pops up
somewhere all I see is a picture of
Ocarina of Time not only does it
represent a big part of my childhood
it's where my love for the series first
started Aina of time was my first Zelda
game and with so many things in life
your first tends to hold a special place
in your heart now ever since I started
this channel I've been yearning to do
some sort of retrospective of my own
however trying toing bring something new
and insightful to the table about Aina
of time has become close to Impossible
at this point in the 25 years since its
release it's been picked apart on almost
every conceivable level we're talking
countless hour-long analyses breakdowns
and trivia going over every little thing
that makes the game tick as such I feel
like the only thing I can really offer
at this point that could be considered
truly unique are my own memories and
experiences from back when I first
played it because even though we all
played the same game essentially the
circumstances in which you did Will
differ from everyone else's you know how
old you were when you first played it
whether you played it alone or with a
friend or a family member did you play
it on release or years after the fact
and on which Hardware these are all
contributing factors to how you perceive
Ocarina of Time and thus each and every
one of us has our own unique stories to
tell and today I want to tell you mine
so sit back relax and let me take you
back to the past and talk about my
experience with OV
[Music]
time
for before we get into the game itself I
feel like I need to outline a proper
setting especially for those of you
under the age of 25 so most of what I'm
about to tell takes place between 1998
and 99 which puts me between the age of
11 and 12 now unless you worked in the
industry at the time most of what you
knew about video games came from
magazines TV commercials and good
oldfashioned word of mouth the internet
did exist technically but it was
primitive to say the least this was
still before Google before Myspace and
other social platforms so if you even
owned a PC to begin with which
definitely was not a given you kind of
just had to know vicariously which
websites to go to for gaming related
content you know stuff like news
walkthroughs forums cheats and so on not
only that but this was years before
Broadband so we were still using dialup
at this point to access the internet and
for those who don't know what that means
just count yourself lucky I also want to
preface that at the time it was very
common for me to play games with other
people in the room which in my case were
my two cousins and I'm not just talking
about multiplayer because you know that
goes without saying but single player
games as well in fact most of the games
I quote unquote beat at the time I
didn't actually finish all by myself
instead we would all hurdle around the
TV and pass a controller around While
others watched just keep that in mind
whenever I use the term we instead of I
anyway the year is 1998 and the tragedy
of Titanic and Jack's physics defying
death scene were still fresh in
everyone's mind Our Story begins not
with Zelda actually but with another
legendary title golden ey7 this was the
game I was obsessed with around the time
acarina hit the scene the campaign
unlocking cheats multiplayer slappers
only of course I got the full James Bond
experience despite the fact that I did
grow up with the NES and SNES I was
completely oblivious to the Zelda
franchise up until now I don't know it
just never got on my radar for some
reason I do remember seeing my neighbors
kids play A Link to the Past for a brief
moment and thinking it looked really
cool however they were predominantly PC
Gamers one of only a few few kids in my
neighborhood who were so I don't know I
guess they must have been using an
emulator or something if that was even a
thing back then or maybe they did have a
Nintendo but were simply using a
computer monitor as a TV or maybe I'm
just misremembering I mean it was a long
time ago either way since my family
didn't own a PC powerful enough to play
anything beyond mind sweeper or chess I
never even bothered to ask what it was
that they were playing and so my
ignorance lived on so by the time
aquarina came out on November 21st 1998
I was once again completely oblivious to
the fact the the only thing I do
remember quite vividly is seeing a
commercial for the game on TV and I
actually found that exact commercial I
think every country kind of got their
own version of it I know there's the
infamous UK commercial that said
something like will you get the girl or
play like one imagine doing that in 2023
but yeah I'm pretty sure this is the
version I saw on TV back in the day
mainly because of this shot of Link
jumping down the waterfall in Zora's
domain which as far as I'm aware is
unique to the European versions I don't
know why this shot in particular sticks
out in my memory so much since it's it's
not exactly the most iconic part of the
commercial but I mean the human brain is
just weird that way I guess anyway as
you may have been able to infer by now I
didn't actually play AAR enough time on
release day in fact I didn't even play
it that same year it wasn't until early
1999 a few months after the game came
out that someone finally brought it to
my attention I will spare you the exact
details but basically we knew a guy who
was considerably older than we were I
think I don't know 15 or 16 at the time
and he's the one who told us about how
he just beat the new Zelda game on the
N64 and how amazing it was so really it
was just a case of well if he played
Zelda we had to play it as well because
he was older and cool so with that
little seed planted firmly into our
brains we did what most kids with an
empty wallet would do at the time we
rented the game which in our case was
free since both my youngest cousin's mom
and my mom worked at the local video
store we popped that sucker in turned on
the
[Music]
console
you know eventually and well needless to
say it was love at first side the
animations the world the music it was
absolutely mind-blowing I mean come on
just look at those sexy polygons I joked
before about the graphics and how they
didn't exactly age very well but it goes
without saying that we didn't know any
better this was it the peak of '90s 3D
Graphics now I know that the N64 was far
from the most powerful system out there
at the time but visually AR time was
still at the very least on par with the
best in the competition even back then
Nintendo was pushing their inferior
Hardware to the absolute limit with
their first party titles just like
they're doing now with the switch of
course it is worth mentioning that most
of the footage of N64 titles you see
online nowadays including the stuff I'm
showing here is not an accurate
representation of how we experienced it
back in the day most of this stuff is
emulated with all kinds of filters and
mods applied to it you know upscaling
anti-aliasing widescreen mods All That
Jazz the image image we saw on our
primitive TVs looked more like something
like this 4x3 240p upscaled which to be
fair was both a blessing and a curse
sure the image was blurry as hell and
you couldn't see a lot of details but on
the flip side those old CRTs and early
LCDs were pretty effective at obscuring
a lot of imperfections especially those
rough edges on 2D Sprites and low
quality textures one of the reasons why
acarina made such a big impression on me
from the get-go is that at this stage I
was still used to games that utilize a
level select screen or some sort of Hub
World AC of time with its interconnected
living breathing world was something I
had never seen before and the same goes
for the story granted a lot of it went
right over my head as a kid I mean
obviously I didn't pick up on things
like subtext or symbolism but everything
you did just felt important you know
like you were part of something much
bigger common nowadays for an adventure
game but for me at that time it was
bigger than anything I'd ever
experienced before this also happened to
be the first game I ever played that had
a day and night cycle in fact one of my
favorite things to do was to explore
Hyrule Field and in particular towns and
Villages after dark there was just
something about that nightly atmosphere
the sound of crows and crickets the
quirky characters that came out after
Sundown seeing the light shine through
the window shades of people's houses as
a kid who's basically forced to go to
bed early at that age the idea of being
out after dark while the world around
you is asleep truly felt like something
special something that in real life you
rarely got to do now as I stated before
my early interactions with a enough time
was on a rented cartridge and because of
this we never managed to get very far
every bit of progress we made was
eventually halted because you know it
had to go back to the video store where
someone else would rent it for a while
and you kind of just had to pray that
your safe file would still be there a
couple of weeks later though more often
than not it would be gone and since
we're on the topic of save files in one
instance while we were still messing
around in the early parts of the game we
eventually let our curiosity get the
best of us and decided to take a quick
peek at someone else's save file it felt
like like gazing into a forbidden part
of the game we weren't supposed to know
about yet like skipping ahead to the
middle of a book or a movie as we booted
up the save file we were met with this
the entrance to the Forest Temple we
didn't play very far in fact I don't
remember taking more than a few steps
probably because we didn't want to spoil
ourselves even further however this
short little moment became the Catalyst
for a major misconception I had about
arrina of time one that I held on to for
way longer than I care to admit as the
image of the Forest Temple faded into
view my cousin said something along the
lines of oh wow link is much bigger here
that single sentence made me believe
that link would gradually grow older as
the story unfolds and my brain would
actually trick me into seeing it that
way too I would walk out of a dungeon
and think yeah I think he looks bigger
you know he's got some more biceps going
on which of course is not true young
Link's character model doesn't change
one bit between dungeons it just goes to
show how you can be fooled into seeing
something when you have a preconceived
idea in your head even more hilarious is
that in one instance the game even even
seem to reinforce my delusion by saying
ho ho it looks like you've gotten a
little bigger and stronger already Dawn
so yeah needless to say I had no idea
about the time travel part which is kind
of ironic seeing as it's pretty much in
the title I will cut my 11-year-old self
some slack since I barely engaged with
anything Ocarina of Time related prior
to picking it up I only saw that
commercial once and at a glance and with
the absence of Internet culture it was
much more common that you went into a
game completely blind it also didn't
help that when you rented an N64 title
you didn't get the cardboard box with it
and not even the manual in most cases
both of which would have been a dead
giveaway but the time travel stuff that
cycle of renting the game playing it for
a few days returning it to the video
store and then usually having to start
all over again would remain the status
quo for the next couple of months until
finally in June 1999 I got my own copy
for my 12th birthday I came home from
school my cousins were there and we
played for hours and hours all the way
through the parts we were already
familiar with and Beyond one thing I
find quite poetic looking back at it now
is the way I experience the child and
adult sections of the game see my
birthday happens to fall close to the
start of that big summer holiday you had
between semesters so my cousins and I
would have ample amount of time to play
together because you know we didn't have
school for a couple of weeks because of
this I played most of the youngling
quest line in the company of other
people which was quite comforting in a
way entering the Royal Family's tomb for
the first time was one of the scariest
most unsettling things I had ever
experienced in a video game up to that
point but at least I had my cousins with
me you know if things became too scary
or too challenging you could just hand
over the controller to someone else and
let them suffer for a while but as the
holiday Drew to a close so did most of
our play sessions together we had to go
back to school so that comfort of
playing with other people largely became
a thing of the past by the time I got to
the adult section I was almost
exclusively playing by myself and it
just so happens that it's at this point
that the game makes a dramatic shift in
tone the world you explored as a kid had
grown darker the bright and colorful
streets of Castle town were now replaced
by a post-apocalyptic hellscape there
was a sudden sense of urgency people
were counting on you I think it's one
reason why the game made such a big
impact on me on an emotional level
compared to say Mario 64 or banjuk kazui
ainaa time is in part A Coming of Age
story and being a kid myself at the time
I essentially had to grow up alongside
link and learn to face my fears this was
even further Amplified by the fact that
I was on the cusp of a major change in
my life 1999 happened to be my last year
of primary school by the end of that
summer I was going to high school which
let's just say I was very nervous about
to say the least I was very short for my
age I looked at least 2 to 3 years
younger than most of my classmates so
the idea of going to this new place with
all these kids that were way older and
bigger than I was it was terrifying and
I think a lot of people can relate to
that going to high school is a big deal
at that age actually one thing that I
just realized that I think is pretty
cool uh so just to clarify this is not
my original copy Cy the one I got for my
birthday that one has unfortunately been
lost to time I I have no idea what
happened to it maybe I don't know it got
lost during a move or maybe my parents
threw it away by accident or maybe
hopefully it's still sitting in a box in
an attic somewhere uh but yeah this is
just a hand-me-down that I bought
specifically for the video uh
however this one right here this is
actually my cousin's copy uh which he
was kind enough to lend out to me and
while as you can clearly see from the
very obvious barcode that they just
slapped shamelessly on top as they
always do this one came from the video
store the very same video store that our
moms used to work at so yeah I don't
know I guess at some point they started
phasing out their N64 Library uh as the
system itself retired and they must have
gifted this one to my cousin at some
point now I don't know how many copies
they had at that particular store but it
can't have been that many because like I
said uh we always had to wait for
someone else to return it and our save
files would be gone again so you know
even though I no longer own my my copy
uh the one with my OG save file on it
that I used to actually beat the game
back in the day um which is unfortunate
there is at least a chance a very good
chance that this might just be that
original cartridge that we rented uh
back when we first played arar of time
you know months before I got my own copy
which I don't know I think it's a pretty
cool idea that this piece of plastic
might just be the first Zelda game I've
ever held in my hands and put in my
Nintendo to to play now with that
personal anecdote out of the way let me
shift the focus back to the actual game
itself and share some specific
highlights of my first playthrough in
chronological order you know those
little moments that stick out in your
memory the most I already mentioned the
Royal Family's tomb and yeah this stuff
was absolutely nightmare inducing it may
sound a bit over dramatic to some of you
especially given the graphics but first
of all I was 12 and second I had never
played real horror games at this stage
like Resident Evil or Silent Hill he the
scariest thing I'd ever experienced was
the piano in Mario 64 which sure was
pretty terrifying as well but this right
here this was a whole different ball
game the moment I laid eyes on that
first rad I made an immediate 180 and
high tailed it out of there like the
coward I was I of course did eventually
come back got the song and all that but
I will never forget how scared I was of
this place even as a cynical adult
setting foot in this place still manages
to evoke that childlike anxiety buried
somewhere deep within another memory
that sticks out for me is the fight with
barinade the final boss of the third
child dungeon jabu jabu's belly it's not
because of the fight itself because
let's be honest it's not exactly the
most memorable boss in the game but
rather the circumstances in which I
defeated it I once saw a video of James
rol AKA The Angry Video Game Nerd in
which he shares his story about beating
Contra on the NES for the first time he
talks about playing it early in the
morning right before school and then
getting to the final boss the school bus
is going to have to wait I'm beating
Contra my dad comes in is like why don't
you pause it that's the classic parent
comeback why don't you pause it I'm like
well how am I going to focus in school
knowing that I have a contra game at
home that is paused on the last stage no
it's something that immediately
resonated with me because I also played
games before school a lot you know right
in that short little window between
waking up and going out the door in his
story he just to beat the final boss
just in the nick of time and is able to
tell his friends about it I however
wasn't that lucky I had been breaking my
balls trying to finally beat this damn
dungeon for what felt like days at that
point and when I finally walked into
that boss chamber early in the morning
my time was up I had to go to school so
I paused it and what James said in his
video about not being able to
concentrate in school knowing he had a
game on pause back at home that is
totally accurate I remember sitting in
class being so afraid that my mom would
accidentally turn turn off my N64 or
even that the console would somehow
overheat from being turned on for too
long it was not an easy school day let's
just put it that way looking back it's
kind of funny because the boss room is
actually not all that far from the
dungeon entrance I could have easily
saved and just pick it up from there but
that's not how I saw it back then jabu
jabu's belly felt like a godamn maze at
the time and to an extent it is it's
definitely a lot less linear than the
first two child dungeons just the mere
thought of having to track through these
hallways once again was unacceptable to
me I wasn't having it once that school
bell rang I rushed home like a madman
was relieved to see that my N64 did not
in fact Catch Fire and was still on
pause safe and sound defeated barinade
which was actually pretty easy and
finally I was ready to go back to Zelda
with all three spiritual Stones when I
think back to the child section of
ocarine of time it feels like it took
such a long time to get through it so
many countless hours it was like a full
game on its own of course this is in
part due to the fact that we had to
start the game all over again so many
times during those initial months you
know when we were still renting it and
I'm sure it also has to do with the way
you perceive time as a kid as opposed to
an adult days and weeks just seem to
last so much longer back then you know
the moment where I got that sneak peek
into someone else's safe file and seeing
the Forest Temple and actually getting
there on my own save truly felt like a
lifetime ago imagine my surprise them
when I found out that there were at
least five more dungeons to get through
I wasn't even close to halfway yet as
for the adult portion of the game I
remember getting stuck a lot enemies
were tougher dungeons were suddenly way
more complex I mean on top of having to
navigate and fight your way through you
now had small keys and a boss key to
deal with as well now when it comes to
Arina of time and getting stuck most
people will understandably point to the
water temple which I do agree was a bit
of a nightmare to get through the first
time however the longest I ever got
stuck that is to say where I made
absolutely zero progress was actually
Inside the Fire temple and it's all
because of this one ridiculous jump you
had to make it took me days to figure
this this one out and I don't do this
very often but in this case I'm blaming
the game on this one not myself because
come on how was I supposed to know that
you're able to make this jump he just
magically snaps onto the ledge despite
so obviously missing it by a mile it's
not even close I feel like the only way
to figure this one out is to just take a
leap of faith out of boredom because
you've exhausted every other option I
mean Jesus Christ oh I still get angry
when I think about this
part anyway another huge roadblock that
gave me a lot of trouble at the time
were the stealth fights inside the
Forest Temple they did an insane amount
of damage compared to anything else you
faced up to that point their jump
attacks were especially devastating with
a whopping four hearts of damage I think
I only had about I don't know seven or
eight hearts total when I got here so
that meant two jump attacks and you're
dead and you had to face three of these
bastards in order to get the bow it's
actually because of this fight that I
first discovered that you can bottle as
many fairies as you have empty bottles
to spare which ended up being my Saving
Grace naturally the fight against
darklink was also extremely memorable so
much so that I kept a separate save file
right before the fight just so I could
face him over and over again or show the
fight to my friends and yes I did
actually defeat him in the conventional
way not by cheesing him because well I
didn't know about that the first time
the only trick I did know and found out
on my own somehow was that the fight is
much easier if you don't use Z targeting
safe to say Dark Link made a big
impression on me I even made an
animation about it several years later
right before I went to college I of
course remember my first time entering
the bottom of the and getting the
proverbial scared out of me I mean
this was essentially the Royal Family's
tomb on steroids so you can only imagine
I also recall beating the spirit Temple
before the Shadow Temple which was
apparently not how most people did it
the first time I know the game does
allow for it but it also clearly nudges
you towards the Shadow Temple first I
don't know maybe the bottom of the well
scared me so much that I needed a change
of scenery for a while by the time I was
finally about to face gondorf I felt
pretty confident battle hardened by all
the previous challenges I marched up
those stairs of the castle ready to kick
some wizard ass that confidence however
turned out to be a complete facade the
first fight was pretty doable I wasn't
particularly scared or anything but as
soon as I realized Ganondorf had a
second form and saw that Dreadful
transformation sequence I did something
I had never ever done before in my life
I paused the game and I called up the
Nintendo hotline I am not even kidding
the image of ganon's dark silhouette
towering over you the lightning the
Flames rising up in the background the
music it was just so intimidating that
it actually made me afraid of losing
against him which is so weird looking
back at it I mean obviously I had game
overs before many times in fact but for
some reason this was different I I just
did not want to lose to this guy I had
to win this first try or go home of
course the fight itself is actually
pretty easy if you know what to do but I
guess I was just so a struck that I
didn't dare to go in blind and find out
on my own I needed some pointers and
quick so I wrecked up my parents' phone
bill just a notch probably without them
knowing I honestly don't even remember
the advice I got from them but whatever
it was I managed I defeated Ganon
executed the final blow and then came
into credits it was finally done in
retrospect the whole thing from start to
finish probably took only about four or
5 months something like that and that's
including the time spent while renting
it but it definitely felt a lot longer
again probably because of time
perception as a kid of course this is
not where my ACA time Journey would end
in the Years following that first
playthrough I would beat the game many
many more times which is actually quite
rare for me there's not that many games
I can revisit over and over most of the
time it's a oneand done deal for me but
there are a few exceptions and acarina
is one of them I must have beaten this
game at least 30 to 40 times at this
point and that's not even counting stuff
like randomizers or the 3DS remake over
the years I became a veteran at the game
and one of my favorite things to do was
to show the game off to other people I
would often invite many different
friends and class classmates over and
when they obliged I would always show
them Arina of time I would play as
flashy as I possibly could purposely
drawing out fights longer than I needed
to just to make them look more intense I
was like the Jehovah's Witness of Aina
of time spreading the word of its gospel
I wanted everyone to see just how
amazing this game was for every new
visitor I would usually create a brand
new save file just for the occasion
which I would eventually finish all the
way through again mostly by myself of
course since they did have to go home at
some point except for poor Timmy I'm
pretty sure he's still stuck in my old
house somewhere anyway I could go on for
hours heck I haven't even touched on the
real life Zelda inspired Adventures we
used to go on venturing into the woods
with sticks and improvised Shields
pretending to be inside of a dungeon or
the wooden Massa sword my grandfather
made me at my request but I think I've
rambled on long enough for one video in
fact I would love to hear your stories
about OV time even though it's been 25
years and the game has since become a
pop culture phenomena back in the day I
actually didn't know that many people
who played Ocarina aside from my cousins
at least not until the internet started
taking off I guess it's why I felt such
a strong urge to show the game to people
and talk about it and with this channel
I've been able to do just that on a
scale I could have never imagined back
when I was 12 so if you will please
leave your stories down in the comments
below I'm looking forward to reading
them a big shout out goes to my cousins
Don and Mike and my brother Jesse for
not only providing me with the classic
Hardware I needed but also for coming
over and reliving some of the past with
me it was good fun finally a quick
thanks to Javit from good blood for
helping me color correct some of the
footage we shot and of course as always
a massive thanks to my patreons and
channel members that is all for now and
I hope to see you all next
[Music]
time
all